try to riff do that joke that you're  scared of doing sometimes when i'm on  stage i'm like  a little nervous out of my element i'm  like this isn't going as well as i hoped  that's when you try the new bit because  that's when you're the most vulnerable  in raw  and it'll actually kick you into being  yourself  it's almost like when you're trying when  you're with a girl and you're trying to  be cool and funny  and it's not going that great just go  well this isn't going that great hold on  let me let me reboot here it just  it's the it's the thing your brain is  telling you don't do  do that sometimes go towards that [ __ ]  it's like the del close thing follow the  fear go towards the fear sometimes and  everything in your brain saying don't  but that's when you should and it makes  the fear go away ironically  go into it lean into the skid